good morning thank you for the uh
welcome and thank you to the conference
organizers
for uh having me i love visiting
bratzwov
and i like talking to your community
this is my talk
when python practices go wrong
i'm not going to talk about python the
language
and its features that might have been
good ideas or might have been bad ones
this morning
that's a different topic and it's also
one that we can't do very much about
once features have been added to the
language they tend to stay
but it can be very impactful to study
our practices around how we use the
language
because those are flexible and continue
to evolve
so i'm going to discuss four different
areas
of python practice today i'll start with
something relatively uncontroversial to
get us started
and look how the community has learned
the good and bad aspects
of using that part of the language and
then i'll finish out with three topics
where my ideas are a little more
controversial because i think the
community still has some things to learn
and still has some practices to perfect
in some other areas so let's get started
my first topic is compiling new code
at runtime python
has they're slightly different an exact
statement
and an eval function as do many dynamic
languages
which let you get a string
at runtime that contains some code that
was not available to the compiler
when your modules were loading you get
that fresh string
you send it to a val it is lexed into
tokens
it is parsed into an ast it is compiled
to by code
and it is run the entire string
to compilation process runs afresh
for the string that you pass so that the
code can run
and produce a result this isn't
available
in languages where the compiler is gone
by the time your application is up and
running it is a feature of dynamic
languages that compiling novel code in
the middle of your application
is possible but is it a good idea
some beginners to a language like python
start using a vowel
for any dynamic operation they can think
of
they think i need to get an attribute
whose name i don't know until runtime
maybe the user is selecting from a menu
and that is when you learn what
attribute you will need to display
such programmers when they are beginning
think that they need to go through that
entire compilation process
in order to say my object dot and the
attribute name
because many early languages were called
dynamic
merely because they offered eval they
were dynamic
purely textually in the sense that you
could construct
new phrases in the language at runtime
python is more powerful than that python
is dynamic
because it offers introspection and
data-driven object
operations without making you build
strings and re-compile them
using eval instead
for example in this case there is a get
adder built-in
that lets an attribute whose name you
have just learned is a string
be looked up at runtime without going
through an entire compilation process
so we steer new programmers in python
away
from a vowel because for whatever
dynamic operation they want to do
whatever introspection they want to do
a better mechanism than a vowel is
almost always
available so how does a vowel wind up
getting used
if thou wound up having a great future
it's widely used in the language today
it's just not where we first expected it
for example you can go look in the
standard library
you will find that we have in the
language
a class factory
it's a function that you call and that
gives you a new class
every time you call it you tell the
language that you want
a a an immutable struct a named tuple
it's called
you tell it the class name you tell it
the list of attributes that you want it
to have
and it generates for you a convenient
class that takes
all of those attributes at instantiation
time
and then can let you access them later
wow python builds classes at runtime
how does it do that if you look under
the covers
it's using exec on a string
it is not painstakingly going through by
little bitty steps and building up a
type object manually
no it just builds a big string which is
the class statement that it wishes
that it had at uh load time
and it runs it with exact and out comes
the class that it wants to return to you
in fact this bothered some people a
contributor
once got on the python bug tracker and
offered an alternative
that instead builds the named tuple
class
without using exec without
recompiling a whole string from scratch
the core developers turned it down they
had tried that before themselves it
turned out
and running the string was faster python
is pretty efficient
at running python and they found it was
easier to get correct
the class statement built a class that
was perfect
or as if they tried to use little
introspection operations to build it it
was easy to get something wrong
or incomplete so templating types
was judged in the standard library to be
a legitimate use of a vowel
another use is called doctests
documentation often in many languages
include
sample code maybe your readme shows what
looks like a little python prompt
with an expression that produces a
result
very often inside of the docs strings
that we try to remember to put at the
top of classes and functions and methods
we might also illustrate because very
often
it's easier to understand an
illustration of what something does
than a textual explanation
show instead of tell
someone seeing these examples once
thought
well what what if we could execute what
if we could run
the code inside of the documentation
then we could see whether the output
still
matches what we claimed the code does
in the documentation and thanks to a
vowel
it's something that you can write
yourself i mean don't try there are some
edge cases that
um that are a bit sharp but the basic
idea is
just go through the text and any lines
that start with what looks like a python
prompt
can be availed turned into a wrapper and
compared with the next line
in the file and what it claims should
come out
when that expression is entered this
became in the standard library the doc
tests module
a standard way that python programmers
keep their documentation
in sync with their code now we did have
some learning to do
there were some downsides some people
started trying to write
all of their tests as doc tests and
there were some problems
it meant then as they wrote a huge
text file to have all of their tests
that the
code snippets were all coupled a mistake
at the top would break everything else
even if those later features in your
class were really working
it was it was just awkward documentation
it would start explaining how the
function works and then would start
talking about all of these edge cases
that you didn't really care about
you realize they were talking about them
because they needed them tested
not because they were really interesting
to you and so
they didn't wind up being a good model
for real tests
but a great great tool
if you keep it limited to testing
documentation
but we had to learn where that mechanism
based on a vowel was useful
and where it was not but what was the
greatest success of
all of a vowel it has to be
the ipython notebook the jupiter
notebook as it's now called this was
easy
uh i believe the project was started by
a scientist
python makes programming that easy
they wrote a loop that takes
input um initially at a prompt but now
also
in cells in the browser it runs eval
on the code that you've sent in and can
send back
graphics images charts data tables
uh and raw python output in an
interactive display
that lets you instead of running your
statistics analysis program in one
shot it lets you load up the data
and then work with it live an ability
powered by a vowel that is making python
the tool of choice
for statisticians scientists and data
people
all around the world today possible
not just possible but easy for someone
to get started implementing
because python is dynamic
eval turns out wound up having only
limited use for application code
i write thousands of lines of python
without ever running eval
but it gets very wide use
usually not in our applications except
in name tuple
but in all of the tools we build around
the code
the tests the development environments
and the tools
i'm now going to go on having used that
as an example topic of how we learn as
we work with a language over the years
about what its features
work well and work badly for
now going to go on to a second topic
let's talk for a minute about python's
object model
the way people use it what is the object
model
well python has a number of operators
that are supported by its built-in types
ins and floats know how to do addition
subtraction
comparison and other operations
but it's not only built-in types that
get to be part of that ecosystem
any class that you write in the python
language
can opt in to the same operators
if it adds special methods that the
language recognizes as special
because they have double underscores at
the beginning and end
like certain symbols in the c and c plus
language
that are special to the pre-compiler the
um
we call these double underscore methods
dunder methods
and they are the way that your classes
if you want
can support built-in python operations
and operators
here are some ways that people have
tried to use those let's look at three
dunder methods
first dunder bull
dunderbool lets your object
participate in if statements while loops
and other built-in constructs that have
to make decisions
true or false based on a value in python
a value really means an object because
everything in python is an object
and your objects by implementing the
method under bool
can also be eligible to be the condition
of an if statement or a while loop many
built-in types have already opted into
this system
to make python comfortable for c
programmers c
plus plus programmers and java
programmers
integers declare themselves false if
they are zero
floats declare themselves false if they
are zero
and all kinds of containers consider
themselves false based on their length
they take their integer length as
determining
whether they are true or false
programmers love brevity
i don't know if you've ever noticed this
or tried to read the code of someone
that tries to be very brief
but in no lesson authority than pep 8
the official standard for how we should
write python code it says this
for sequences strings lists
tuples when doing if tests and while
loops
use the fact that empty sequences are
false
what habit is this trying to encourage
it's trying to encourage this
a beginning programmer writes this if
the length of the sequence is greater
than zero
but then they learn more about python
and they say wait
zero is already false i don't have to
compare myself to zero
if i want to skip the body of the if
statement for
a zero value all i have to say is if
len of sequence and it means the same
thing
then they learn a little more python and
they realize well wait a minute
sequences already judge their own truth
or falsehood
by their length i can just say
if sequence it's officially recommended
in pep 8
and it just makes developers feel good
because it's
fewer characters problem
and this is something i only really
realized in the last year or two when
working on very big code bases
python code is always in danger
of becoming a type desert
i mean uh empty and barren wasteland
and the sun is beating down on you
as you walk through the heat thirsty
for any knowledge of what types the
variables are
this isn't so much a problem in smaller
programs but
in a huge system hundred thousand lines
of code
you can run across a routine like this
and ask
what is the type of users
the only hint you are given is that it's
used in an if statement
how much does that tell you almost
nothing
anything can have a dunderbool method
because the object in an if statement
can be anything
it could be a user collection that has
defined a dunderbool method
it could be a normal python list but of
user objects
it could be a list of usernames
that could legitimately be called users
in fact
i've been in code where i suspected one
of these things
added a debugging print statement and
found that users was
12. some people don't always call that
user count or number of users they think
users is clearly a number
it might not be clear to the reader six
months later or
even to the author
in the zen of python which i hope you
have displayed on your screen
as you sit with your tea or coffee in
the morning and get ready to code python
when you type import lists this and the
zen of python prints on your screen
you see that statement explicit
is better than implicit
in python code where as systems become
larger and larger it's often a difficult
question
what the type of a variable is might not
be a good hint
i have found myself stepping back from
that pep 8
recommendation and keeping
things explicit rather than implicit
making it clear to myself giving myself
a reminder
whether the if statement is attempting
to make a judgment on the size of a
container
or a judgment on the value of an integer
those of you who have used the language
will will guess where i got
this last year i had to do some work on
a code base that was in go
go does not believe in implicit trueness
or falseness
you have to do the comparison you have
to show your work when i came back to
python
the if statement almost looked
unfinished when it just said if users
so i didn't tell anyone i'd just been
using go but i wrote the if statement
explicitly
where i could see what it was testing
and i suddenly felt that more knowledge
was being left in the code
than when i omitted it don't tell anyone
try it and see if it does the same thing
for you
maybe it will work maybe it won't but
that's an area where i'm finding a
common python practice
deprives my code of knowledge that maybe
i'd prefer it retained
all right a second part of the object
model is called
get adder this is a fallback for if
you try to look at an attribute of an
object that doesn't exist
if c dot foo isn't there but get adder
is defined
then you can have dynamic code that
decides on the fly
whether there is a foo attribute or not
either raises
attribute error if it thinks it
shouldn't exist or returns a value for
it
and a client can't easily tell the
difference between
whether uh that that was a real
attribute that was there already or
whether you made it up on the fly
this powers some very important patterns
for instance the proxy pattern in the
gang of four
a standard design pattern if you are
wrapping a class with 30 methods
traditionally requires you to implement
30 methods in your proxy
it's much much simpler in python because
all the attributes a person tries to
look up on your proxy
can dynamically be dispatched through
to lookups on the wrapped object
and then you can add an if statement if
you want to do something special which
is the point of a
proxy object so some patterns become
fastly simpler simple vastly more simple
in python
because of this dynamic ability
well people got another idea instead of
wrapping another object
what if we made something that appears
to have every method you can think of
if you look up a name it will say ah yes
i have a method of that name and return
to you a function
but it could instrument that method to
record
every time it's called and what
arguments it's called with
you get an object that knows
whatever methods you try to call will
suddenly seem to exist
and will be recorded and this is now in
the standard library
and available to power your tests
a test instead of actually letting you
connect to the database or allocate a
window in the operating system
can instead create a mock object call
your code
and see if the correct set of operations
was done
that's so great so powerful what could
be the problem
mock the widely used
encourages tests that in one sense are
not
really tests the ideal is to have unit
tests that get
small collections of functions or
classes
make calls to their facade their outer
layer of calls and see how they behave
and then integration tests that really
hook code together to see what it does
together i have seen code bases
where the code is never actually hooked
together like it would really work
where every single test is simply
testing
a piece of code against a mock so the
only guarantee you have is that it works
against a fake object
but you never actually know until your
customers try the code
whether it really works my complaint
then
is that in fact tests start to lose
signal
when mock becomes routine instead of a
reluctant workaround
and i think our docs and blog posts too
often focus
on how to use mock i feel like i've seen
a dozen blog posts with that title
rather than also telling you when you
should use mock
and that it has downsides and dangers
a final built-in bit of dynamicness we
like to take advantage of is called
dunder call the python syntax
f followed by some parens is an operator
named a call
f in that syntax is often a function or
method
but it could be any other object instead
any object can define that dunder method
and opt in
and so if you have a template class
that only really does one thing useful
render
you give it some keyword arguments and
the text gets filled in
well programmers love brevity and they
think well i
only have one real method i don't have
lots and lots of things the template can
do
to just that need to be distinguished
from each other does the one method
really need a real name
they look down at the bottom of the
screen look at that they're wasting
seven characters dot render
well that's the only thing a template in
its right mind would do anyway
and so they make this pivot they switch
the verb that the template performs
to dunder call so that now the template
simply acts like
a function it takes some parameters and
returns a string
and they are now happy and at peace with
their code having saved seven characters
every time the template is used what's
the problem
readability i realized this when i was
debugging inside of a framework one day
and saw a call like this
get template args close paren open paren
close paren open paren close paren
what are those parentheses doing i had
no
idea uh it turns out does anyone
remember xhtml
crazy crazy times this was back in the
era of xhtml
the first pair of parens built an object
graph that represented xml
objects the second pair of parens then
flattened them the flame
plain text could i tell that by reading
the code
no i'm sure it felt clever to give each
of those objects a default verb
with a dunder call method that didn't
even have to have a name
but i am going to come out against that
practice
i prefer to just burn some extra
characters
have the line be a little longer and
know what the code is doing
know what operation is being performed
i at all costs avoid under call in favor
of real method names
but wait i hear you call you've thought
of an exception
what if i'm working with an api that
expects a plane callable
then my class definitely needs a dunder
call method
i have an excuse if i am going to pass
t to a framework and the framework says
pass me a callable i have no choice
i'm going to have to be brief and add
dunder call
to my class so the class needs a dunder
call right
my answer is no no it doesn't because of
a neat feature of python
called a bound method the syntax
t dot method name does not have to be
followed by a pair of parentheses
triggering the method it by itself
performs an operation that javascript
and other languages
call bind that can be done i believe in
c plus plus with a wrapper function
dot by itself in python goes ahead and
does that operation that requires more
work in other languages
t dot render
is a plain callable x just like a
function
but when called is a method
on the particular object you use to the
left of the dot
so even if your framework requires a
callable that doesn't mean that the
method
can't have a name all right
those are a few observations of where i
think people have gone a little too far
in enjoying python's object model
have maybe hurt their code's readability
in the process
my third topic getting serious now
python's mutability mutability the
ability
of things you've defined in your code
to then start changing at runtime that
sounds like a bad idea
it generally is let's look
for example modules and classes in
python are mutable you
might you might have written them one
way but they can be changed
later if someone is feeling unwise or
adventuresome
if you import the default module string
and you don't like how limited the set
of ascii letters is
you can go change that constant to a new
list of letters that you prefer
the language won't stop you you'll be
entered interested to see then how the
rest of your application runs
with this constant having been changed
in a class you might set a class
attribute value to 1
but someone can always come in later and
change it to 2
because classes are mutable
in fact not even methods are safe
you can come in later overwrite a method
with a new definition that you prefer
and the rest of the application will run
with the new method
in place instead this as you might guess
has over python's history
resulted in some predictable mayhem
did i mention that programmers dislike
repetition
here's the sort of things they try they
love
saying i use the dry approach don't
repeat yourself
and someone i won't name them was
writing a web framework
and they noticed that if you pass the
an object representing the incoming web
request to your views
your code has so much repetition
request request request all the way from
the top
to the bottom of your application
clearly this needs to be fixed they said
hey
python global objects are mutable global
object doesn't have to be a constant
it can be a live object whose attributes
change
let's eliminate the repetition they
decided to do this
oh let's not pass in the request as an
argument
oh let's eliminate all that repetition
and have it be a global object that you
import
and then behind the scenes when a web
request comes in
after importing your module it can for
the
new web request it's received overwrite
the attributes of the request object
with the
properties of the new web request and
then call your code that will
see in that imported class instance
the information that it needs this it
turns out
i think i will argue is a bad idea
data when you come back to debug
something in the middle of the night
later because
a customer has run into a problem data
is now
entering that function from two
different directions you can no longer
read the argument list
and have in your head all of the things
that could change the function's
behavior
instead live data is coming in from some
import statements
that could also affect the outcome of
your view function
tests are now going to have to mutate
that global object before calling a view
in order to completely control the
decisions that it's making
threads are going to have to overwrite
that one request object you're going to
have to put a thread local
in place so that different threads all
looking at the same global
can see a different set of attributes
and an async framework
will now break your web framework
unless you teach the async framework
that each co
routine is going to need its own um
request object swapped into that global
right before the code is called and
that's difficult if you've imported it
and it needs to be injected into the
views module so there are a number of
downsides to this
i just prefer the repetition so that i
can see
the data that my view is acting on it's
bad
but guess what the situation can get
even worse there's another python web
framework
that i won't mention that asked why
import requests at all
if you have 10 different modules with
views
uh you're having to repeat import
requests at the top of every one of them
it's maddening don't repeat yourself and
so that web framework
loads your module full of views that
reference a request that's never
mentioned
and it doesn't matter because it sets
it gives your module a new global at run
time
before calling any of your views so
request is
magically there without boilerplate
developers hate boilerplate and this
gets rid of it
the code is shorter it also means that
you now
unless you know the special rule can't
see where request comes from
it appears magically and your ide
has no idea where it comes from
say goodbye to tab completion say
goodbye to right-clicking
every time you mention request little
wavy red line underneath because vs code
can't see where it came from
it was done in the name of making code
more brief
i'm not sure that it made it more
readable or more useful
global state it's useful in emergencies
but
shouldn't we discovered i would argue be
used routinely
what would an emergency be that might
justify global state i'll just briefly
mention that
gating is a big problem out in silicon
valley
right deep inside of some code you talk
to a database
and now someone comes to you and says oh
we're starting a beta
it's private it's just three of our
customers and we need them to connect to
a different database
well good grief by the time you're down
that low in the code
you don't know who you can't get at the
current request you don't know who the
current user is
and the team hasn't been passed down
there for you to make the decision
you could go through all of your code
and start passing team everywhere
but the experiment ends in four weeks or
it's supposed to if someone remembers to
back it out
and you don't feel like modifying lots
of code that shouldn't have to know
about the team
just because we're doing an experiment
for a customer at a low level
that is a situation where i've seen
grudgingly used to good effect
to get uh knowledge deep in a routine
shouldn't normally need to know it
because we're
we're doing an experiment changing some
behavior based on something the code
wouldn't normally know
but except for situations like that i
try to avoid
passing knowledge to routines through
globals
i prefer instead to speak to them with
arguments
another use of code mutability is in
code that's about
other code like tests
unittest.mock has another feature
that i haven't mentioned yet it is
called patch
it manages mutability in a much more
robust way than if you are running
around
trying to set values or install new
methods on your own
patch is used with a with statement
and while the indented code block
beneath the width is running
c dot method is going to be replaced
by another callable that you provide
and patch is very very careful whether
the block of code
gets killed with an exception or whether
the block of code
in successfully patch makes the
guarantee
that the original cdot method is put
back
by the time the block ends so you don't
break all of the rest of your tests
with a temporary maneuver patch lets you
run
with a class a function or a method
briefly substituted
for something else patch has therefore
become the official mechanism for
testing code that's coupled to side
effects
let's consider some simple code you loop
over some books
for each book you want to fetch it so
you build a url
for each url at the very low level you
go
and do an http request to a server to
fetch some information
simple enough question
how much of that code on the previous
slide can you
test without triggering real http
start on the right all right we can't
call download without
real http trying to run because it does
a url open
but notice that that's also true of the
other routines if you call fetch
it will call download and a real http
request tries to go out on the network
if you call getbooks it inevitably calls
fetch which inevitably calls download
which does real io
it turns out that not a single level of
this hierarchy is callable
without real i o trying to take place
are you going to need to run a small web
server on localhost
in order to test get books over there on
the left
none of that code in fact can be tested
without a web server up and running the
code
succeeds in abstracting away the i o
if you read the top level you don't see
any raw
http requests but it fails to actually
decouple it
even though you can't see the web
request being built if you're up at the
top level
it still is an inevitable consequence of
running that code it's not decoupled
from it
what is the solution to that if you want
to be able to test
get books okay first the real solution
is to turn your whole application upside
down
look at my talks or other people's talks
on the clean architecture
or in other communities it's called the
hexagonal architecture
where you turn software upside down
i o should happen up at the top level
the business logic that are in the
subroutines
shouldn't know where data is coming from
or where it's going
that makes the lower levels easy to test
they're often pure functions
and then it's only when the top level is
called
that you're in danger of real i o taking
place
okay but what's the second best solution
many of us are stuck in situations where
we can't completely re-architecture
right now
and things like the clean architecture
are still emerging in
the java community the c-plus plus
community in python
you might not yet know the clean
architecture well enough to architect
everything you normally code in that way
so if we want to keep the i o
on bottom coupled to everything else but
be able to test
that's when we use patch you go patch
that i o
call url open and now can call that top
level function
get books knowing that sample data
from your patched version will be passed
back to it in the test
rather than a real web request trying to
take place
unfortunately not all programmers stop
there
there is a worst case you can move to
where instead of patching the io
you think oh well if patching is a good
idea let's not even have get books talk
to fetch
let's make a fake fetch
routine so that all i'm doing is testing
get books
some people think that unit testing
means each little thing needs its own
tests
whereas in fact unit tests means create
a unit
by choosing some uh edge
of a smaller system and only test things
from that edge
but it doesn't have to be as small as
one class or function
the unit could be this whole little
cascade of three functions when people
create units that are too small and are
always using
patch instead of letting get books
really
call fetch then the same problem happens
as with mock
you often get tests that don't actually
test
whether your application will work for
your customers when the real functions
are operating together like testing
objects with only mocks
testing functions with all their
subroutines patched
falls short of being a real test and you
lose half the benefit of testing why
because there's two reasons we should
write tests one
an automated alert when code is broken
because it's better than your customer's
telling you but two
noticing that oh good grief i can't i
can't call get books
without patching io is a hint that your
architecture could improve
writing tests and noticing do you need
patch and mock all the time is pressure
that helps you understand that your
architecture needs to pivot
towards more pure functions if you're
always patching and mocking the problem
away
you lose that signal to improve
architecture
so python is dynamic and allows us to
change things at runtime
for tests that's good heavily coupled
code
if you've written it you can move
forward it's still testable in python
thanks to patch
but there's a downside the bad is that
overuse of patch not only makes tests
less meaningful but ruins what the tests
would teach us
about our code's architecture one last
danger of mutability is import time side
effects
python modules are executed top to
bottom at import time
each module starts as a blank slate and
runs its code sequentially
this is a surprise and this is different
than many
compiled languages not only can a for
loop
for example run inside of a function if
you just
unindent you can have a for loop that
runs and does io
at import time now why would you ever do
dangerous or bad things at import time
it happens
like this one you start with your
configuration
name and port of the database living in
the python code
number two on a dark night you discover
that that's an
awful thing to do because a customer
calls with an error you roll back to
yesterday's
version and because your configuration
is in your code you're also trying to
use yesterday's name for the database
server which you had migrated last night
and you're now talking to the old data
so you switch
you now understand that config shouldn't
live in your code
you switch to loading config from a file
but it's the middle of the night and
it's easiest just to do it from that top
executable level of the module because i
mean
opening a file it's what python does
as it loads all your py files and
compiles them
right it's in the same spirit as what
import is doing anyway at import time
opening the little json file where
you've now put the config
feels so much like importing a python
module that we just go ahead and do it
at the top level
so then later it's another programmer
that
is at the helm when the config moves
inside a database
and that code at the outside level of
the module now tries to talk to postgres
to get the config where you're keeping
it centralized
for everyone to read and then the
database port
moves to zookeeper you can't even talk
to postgres
until you've connected with zookeeper
the result
a module that can't be imported or
tested
until zookeeper and postgres are both up
or you will get an error at import time
and it will fail my advice
is to never start down that road
admit no import time side effects at the
moment you're tempted to add some
executable code to the outside of the
module
instead create a setup function that you
call over as the first thing in your
main routine
you want to keep your code importable
without trying to talk to the database
trust me
one last thought about this topic
you could do all kinds of things in a
module and i see people trying to do all
kinds of things specifically
in the dunderinit.pi if you have a
package a directory called my package
import my package and fax in fact
imports that dunderinit.pie
if you say import mypackage.models
first the dunderinit.pi is run then
models.pi
if you say import mypackage.views
dunderinit.pi is imported first in views
then durinitpop.pi is thus an obstacle
and a
cost in the way of all of the other
modules
that you might want to import
programmers keep
putting code there adding expense
to any little thing you might want to
import
from the modules beneath it and worse
yet summed under init up high files for
convenience
import all of the modules beneath them
thus ruining your ability to ability to
cherry pick one thing you want
you now can't touch the package without
waiting to load everything
inside of it my advice which is not what
everyone would say
is to keep dunderinit.pie empty of code
look at my skyfield project skyfield's
dunderinnet.pi
has its dock string so your ide can tell
you what sky field is
but it has no code i do understand that
my users don't want to have to
import things manually from all dozen of
my modules
so i have an api module that imports all
the important classes
so you can save from skyfield api import
and the list of everything you want i
don't make people go ransack
each of my modules separately for the
classes they need
but it is possible to provide that
centralized location where
all your classes can be accessed without
making dunderitnet.pi expensive
so consider pivoting to dunder init.pies
that are
empty all right that ends
my thoughts on some practices around
immutability
i have one last topic to discuss
object orientation indeed the difficult
and fraught topic
of the subclass
i will give an example there is an old
module
uh called threading it has an object
called a thread
as you might expect you can get a
function you it
defines a sequence of things to do you
can create a thread
and start it running that function
but there's a second way to use thread
you also as an alternative can create a
specialized
subclass of it that has a run method
that has all of the lines of code that
you want to execute
it provides two different ways that you
can provide
thread with the code you want to run
subclassing is a slightly awkward choice
you now have
two new objects a class and a method
instead of just one
extra four spaces of indentation you
can't now
test the tasks code in isolation you
have to instantiate a thread first
it's a bit awkward but it is an option
it is an illustration of a difference
very crucial between composition and
specialization which i define as follows
composition means putting simple things
together
specialization means making one thing
more complicated
crucial topics in software
a problem i have is that python provides
an extra temptation that some
languages don't have towards using
specialization as the way you construct
software
it happens in something called the m
times in
problem this is described among other
places in the gang of four book design
patterns
you discover some of your programs a
programmer's subclassing window
because different operating systems work
differently
oh but some of your other developers
have been subclassing it
to adapt it to different layout
algorithms
normally this now means you're going to
need as many sub classes as there are
operating systems times different layout
algorithms
the gang of four say that you can get
out of this
m times in problem through something
they call the bridge pattern
have two separate class hierarchies
windows that are the low level
operations and layouts which
use those low level operations you then
at runtime
can get two class instances and at
run time compose them together where one
holds a reference to the other
where the layout algorithm has a
reference to the window it should be
using
for drawing thus an m times in
problem where you have a geometric
number of classes you need to define
is reduced to an m plus in problem you
only need
one os window one version of each layout
and you can mix and match them at
runtime freely
as needed i will mention in passing
that i think there is another pattern
that in generality is even out beyond
the bridge pattern
you can use data to couple code
instead of behavior the gang of four
don't spend much time on this idea
you can have a layout routine that given
the size the metrics
of the view doesn't talk to any other
code at all
but simply produces some data a list of
graphics objects that need to be drawn
that you can then pass to window.render
without the two pieces of code knowing
each other's interface at all
but instead only knowing the data
classes it's a little more work because
you have to define the data classes
it takes more code but it completely
decouples
the two pieces of code and even lets you
jump in and do things like
post processing the graphics objects
before the window sees them
is there any advantage to coupling with
nouns
instead of with verbs with methods i
like the insight of fred brooks writing
in 1975 he famously said
show me your flow chart your code
and conceal your tables your data
structures
and given just your code i shall
continue to be mystified
but show me your data structures i won't
usually need to see your code it will be
obvious
if fred brooks was right coupling
classes with data structures
will be easier to understand than
coupling them
with behavior and so this is called
usually the pipeline pattern where
each element of software is able to run
to completion producing data
and it's the top level of your code
which hooks them together
which provides the relationship between
them instead of the classes needing to
know that each other
exists so the m by n
problem bad pattern bridge is the gang
of four solution
pipeline is if you move all the way to
the code
not knowing each other about not knowing
about each other at all
and now python comes into the picture
and python has a solution which doesn't
even make you go all the way to the
bridge pattern
python provides a temptation to not even
go all the way to that solution
by doing something else which are called
mixins let's look at an early experiment
that still lingers in the python
standard library
now i'm not criticizing the programmer
of this because it was the 1990s
which were crazy times we were just
beginning to learn how a powerful
object-oriented language should work
they wrote something called a socket
server a base class
for writing services that receive
incoming requests from the internet
these are the methods of
base server there's a lot of them
you might think wow that's a pretty big
interface for users of this class to be
calling
it turns out most of these methods are
not the public interface they're visible
in the public interface but you should
never call them the documentation
specifies this
there are only three of these which are
in fact the external api
that today we would move out into a
facade class but here the three api
calls that you use to start and stop the
server
are mixed in with all of these other
methods that you're never supposed to
touch
because it's when you call those public
those three main
methods that they then call activate
server bind server service actions
and then as a new request comes in and
the asterisk by the way
means that you're supposed to specialize
those you're invited when you subclass
this
to adjust those if you need to to be
particular to your service
you're not supposed to specialize handle
request because it has a lot of
complicated logic
if you want to customize it there's
three more methods that it calls
that you can make more specific if your
service needs to do special things
to get the request to verify that ip
should be talking to you or not
and then to process it process request
if you don't overwrite it
calls by default finish request
which is actually what handles the
request we finally actually do respond
to the customer and
and send some data back because finish
request could raise an exception or hit
a timeout process request runs it
inside of an exception handler and you
can specialize subclass
handle error or handle timeout if there
are special cleanup actions that your
server needs to do
if a request dies in either of those
particular ways
this single class is in fact
several layers of behavior
you can see them right here it it takes
it it took me 10 or 20 minutes of
reading the docs to put this together
and figure out where the layers were
but there are clear layers within this
class that are interacting
why are there so many behaviors on a
single class
well largely because it was 1990 and
back then the idea in object orientation
was that the point of having classes was
modeling
if you have managers and employees in
your database
you want a manager class and an employee
class
that was the idea they had back then if
we only have two nouns when we're doing
low level socket operations you can have
a listening socket or a connected socket
you necessarily will only have two
classes
a base server and a handler
and you get everything having to do with
a server and stick it on one class
and everything having to do with this
request
and put it on the other if your training
is to think of classes as structs for
modeling the world
you'll create one class for each noun
instead of for each interface or
behavior
with the result that you'll generally
have too few
classes you'll model patterns of
behavior with
dense graphs of method calls on the same
object
instead of clean separate interfaces
you'll wind up with one big multi-story
class instead of
several sleek single story classes that
then cooperate together
the bridge pattern tries to get you to
split things into layers
abstraction and implementation in
separate class hierarchies
the s in the solid principle if you
follow that set of object-oriented
guidelines
the single responsibility principle says
classes should have only one reason to
change
if used two different reasons to
specialize a class
then maybe it's two classes hiding
inside of one
alas the base server has many reasons to
change
so many different directions that the
single class needs
to be specialized it really
wants to be broken into separate layers
each of which has a single purpose with
the again a facade
that provides only the public methods
and back behind it
clean interfaces you can specialize to
specialize the network behavior and to
specialize what the service does with
the data
it receives yes three different classes
at least
are needed here to wrap a single actual
resource
in the end there really is only one
listening socket
but to properly model its behavior we
need
three classes not one
so given the situation it's got itself
into
how does the base server class survive
needing to be customized in different
directions at once
mix-ins the fact that in python if you
declare a class
it doesn't need to have any relationship
to the class that's being combined with
threading mix in doesn't inherit from or
adhere to
or or have an interface that relates to
anything else
it's just a bare little class with one
method if
when i create my service class i list
threading mix in first in the list
its method will be preferred over base
server's version of the method
for processing the request that is how
the socket server
survives its problem you select the base
class you could have done it the other
way but you select the base class in
this case according to the protocol you
want on the network then you
mix it with a mix in that provides
different concurrency models
that's how it lets you specialize in two
directions at once
without needing m times in different
classes
mix-ins let you extend a class in
several directions at the same time
without solving the actual problem which
is that the class is too complicated
so that i think is in one way
a strength but in one way a weakness of
python
is that you can get around actually
solving a problem that requires a real
design
pattern by stopping short of it and just
using mix-ins with your overco overly
complicated class
instead it's nearly 20 20
and the reason i bring this up is that
new python books
are still recommending mix-ins as the
best of breed design pattern
i saw one the other day there is a major
python web framework that thinks that
mix-ins are the way to build
views this is still an active
design pattern in the python community
that i think has better alternatives
i mean poor architect texture is going
to happen
despite our best efforts so it's
wonderful that python does have
powerful mechanisms for surviving it
when it happens
but mexins too often i think become
routine
instead of an emergency survival
mechanism so
in conclusion looking back at all of
these examples of the way that python is
very powerful
but that lets you work around things i
say that python is a flexible and
powerful language
it's so powerful that we often work
around
poor architecture without noticing it a
powerful language then by itself
is not enough the ease and power of the
python language
need to be combined with the experience
of its community
for healthy long-term software projects
thank you all for your attention i'm
brandon rhodes
you